- Well, one of your movies,
"A Walk to Remember,"
which is one of my sister's
personal favorite movies
of all time.
It's turns 20 this year.
- [Mandy] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Which I'm a little upset about
that you look the same.
- You're uh, Kelly.
- [Kelly] You're like,
some of us change, Mandy.
- I was 16 in that movie.
- [Kelly] And some of
us just go in some cryo,
like, I don't know what happens,
but you look like you looked
like there, like it's crazy.
- You're kind.
- No, it's a great skincare regimen?
- I was a baby and that's
a nice fuzzy picture.
Thank God for old like Polaroids.
Yeah, no, I turned 17 on that movie.
It is wild that it's 20 years old.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- It's wild that people still
connect with that movie.
It still resonates, clearly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like I like being a part of
projects that make people cry.
- [Kelly] No, but you
with a message, yeah.
- [Mandy] No, it's a great message.
- Yeah.
- [Mandy] For sure, yeah.
- It's beautiful.
And 17 being a lead in a movie,
that seems like a little nervous.
I'd be a little nervous.
- I didn't know what I
was doing, thank goodness.
- [Kelly] So, that's good.
- My co-star Shane West,
like had to introduce me
how to hit a mark.
You know, you were supposed
to like hit your mark
to make sure you're in
the right camera position.
I would like walk up to my mark
and look down like a total amateur.
- Oh yeah.
- I didn't know, it was my
first like onscreen kiss.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, it was everything.
- [Kelly] Is it?
Okay, my first kiss was
technically onstage too
in like a musical in like high school.
And I was like, this is
not how I pictured it.
This was, everyone's watching.
It was really uncomfortable.
- You get like the awkwardness
out of the way maybe.
And then there's like less
pressure when it happens
in real life.
- Nah, then when it really
happened, it was gross, yeah.
He was like searching for something.
I was like, there's nothing there,
you're not gonna find anything.
It was just really uncomfortable.
- [Mandy] Well, yeah.
- Yeah, all the first
kisses, they ruined me.
But people don't realize
if you're in the entertainment
industry or some form,
like that could be your first kiss.
And mine was onstage, it was awkward.
- It was, yeah, it was definitely awkward,
but I also really liked it.
I mean, you're like getting
to kiss a handsome boy.
There's no way that boy
would kiss me in real life.
- [Kelly] Yours was different.
- Yeah.
- I had known this boy
since like childhood,
and now he's like a brother.
I was like, I guess.
- [Mandy] Not a great choice, yeah.
- Not a, yeah it was uncomfortable.